Your loved ones are dying
and zombies are coming for your flesh.
There's no way out
except through one train to Busan,
but you'll never get there.
What do you do? I'm going to break down
the mistakes made what you should do
and how to beat the zombies
in Seoul station.
No one knows it yet,
but by morning, over 30 million
people will die as the sun sets
on a peaceful Seoul.
For the very last time,
a homeless man is bleeding out from a bite
mark as he walks into Seoul station.
The man then plops down
near the stairs in a metro full of people.
The deadliest virus in human
history is flowing through his body,
and he is about to get everyone killed
by nightfall in another part of town.
We see Hye-Sun, an unemployed bum
or she might as well be,
waking up in her boyfriend's tiny, messy
apartment and goes looking for him.
The rent is due and
the landlord is pissed.
Hye-Sun finds her boyfriend
at an Internet cafe and catches him
trying to pimp her out online for cash.
And she flips out.
A fight breaks out.
And cue the yelling in tears
because it's oh, so sad.
The boyfriend then breaks up
with her and storms off.
And now, with no boyfriend
and no home, Hye-Sun breaks down crying.
She decides to head to Seoul Station,
where the homeless
are to seek shelter for the night,
not realizing that
this horrifying night isn't over.
In fact, her "fun
times" are just about to start.
Meanwhile, the boyfriend meets up
with a man who responded to the ad
he posted online.
Turns out this man is Hye-Sun's father
and he's royally pissed and forces
the boyfriend to take him to Hye-Sun.
Little does the boyfriend
know that Hye-Sun's
daddy will destroy everything
he loves soon enough.
Back at Seoul Station, Hye-Sun is walking
past rows of homeless people and suddenly
a bunch of men run past her terrified
and that's when she sees it.
A horrifying zombie pouncing on the warm
flesh of a human, terrified
at what she sees.
Hye-Sun starts running for her life.
That's a bona fide zombie,
if I've seen one.
And now we're in trouble
because we're about to be alone
with undead flesh eating monsters
who will never not stop feeding ,
which means we're screwed.
But we don't have time to think, because
in this situation, it's fight or flight.
And I'm definitely choosing flight
because I'm cold in a tight dress
and not prepared for anything.
There's actual zombies here.
I can't do shit and forget arming yourself
with anything, because down here,
we're already at a disadvantage
being cornered and outnumbered.
We don't need to fight. We need to run.
I don't need to be the fastest.
So long as I'm not the slowest.
And if I can run past
the older people, I guarantee
the zombies will pick them over me.
In fact, if we wanted to be
even more heartless,
I'd purposely trip, stop and push anybody
I see on the way out of the metro.
They may have a head start on me,
but I'm younger, more agile,
at least compared
to their malnourished, starved selves.
If you all wanted to be extra sneaky,
I would have darted
right behind the exit from the metro,
behind that little wall there.
If the zombies line of sight was cut off
from the corner of the wall
for just a second,
that would have been time.
I could have used to hide
and run in the opposite direction
whilst the suckers
lead them the other way.
Hye-Sun and the others
find their way into a police station
where they beg the cops to listen to them,
claiming the people have gone mad.
The world is about to end.
And these cops, of course, don't
listen until the brain hungry suckers
come crashing through the door
but Hye-Sun and a group decide
to hold up in a cell as a last resort.
Turns out one of them is bitten
and the cop guy isn't looking too hot.
He makes a stand as he threatens
everyone with his pistol,
knowing what they know
that HE'S ALREADY DEAD.
Then tank top dude
makes lemonade with the situation
and beats the shit out of cop guy,
causing him to pass out for good
at the same time.
Hye-Sun grabs the gun in shock and fear
until a tank top dude swipes it from her.
Just then, cop guy
comes back from the dead, biting this guy
until he gets shot in the big thinker
by tank top dude. Like
this was a bad situation from the start.
I wouldn't have even stopped
by the police station to begin with.
There are way too many zombies coming
for us if we wanted some police attention.
I would have at the most grabbed
a piece of rock while it's running
to throw the police glass door,
which would have gotten the attention
of the cops without slowing me down.
But since we already cornered ourselves,
zombies are already
something that people would have
had a hard time believing.
But unlike tank top dude
whining to the police,
I wouldn't have used the word insane.
Instead, I would have yelled and screamed
that there was a huge fire outside,
which would have been much more believable
and would have gone to the cops
to get off their asses.
Now, no cop in their right mind
would let me hide under their desk,
especially if they didn't know
what was going on to begin with.
And using anything to change
the door would have been useless
since it's made of glass
and doesn't seem to be bulletproof.
I would have only gone through there
in order to divert the zombies
by going through the station
and out through one of the few exits
that police stations usually have, either
exiting through the employee entrance,
the intake entrance or the emergency exit.
However, I would have only done this once
the zombies entered the police station
to make sure that no cops
try to stop me or worse, tase me.
As the last thing we want to be is free
fried food for these brain munchers.
And if we're talking about brain munchers,
we as a society have gone to the point
where zombies are common
pop culture knowledge.
They didn't need to wait for that
bitten cup to get up and bite hoodie guy
in order to have known that he was.
Going to turn into a zombie. Stop
being stupid, stupid.
Hye-Sun Lee's trapped with tank top dude
as the zombies outnumbered their bullets.
They will die if they don't do something,
but then help suddenly arrives,
or at the very least, a distraction.
As riot control shows up
late to the meat party,
the zombies attack them as Hye-Sun
and tank top dude
bolt out of the back
entrance of the station,
narrowly escaping through the small alley
until they run into an ambulance.
It's chaos everywhere as ambulance
guy quickly picks them up and drives off
He tries to treat both Hye-Sun
and tank top dude. But something is up.
Hye-Sun checks her phone and realizes
she's got missed calls
from her ex-boyfriend and ambulance guy,
then tells them that the hospital
they're heading to
is full of bite victims.
So they'll have to wait their turn.
But tank top guy waits for nothing
as he freaks out and demands the ambulance
to stop getting physical with the driver,
causing them to crash.
All right, This whole nonsense
could have been avoided
if they just layered their efforts
with some calm, cool collectedness.
I would have used the time
the riot squad gave me as time.
I could have used to scavenge
what I could quickly
from the police station,
such as checking out anything
I could have used for armor
and the armory for weapons, as it likely
would have only been accessible
with a key card.
So I would have checked out
Cop Guy's corpse in the jail cell first.
Now, there were quite a few zombies,
but from the looks of things,
the riot squad seemed to outnumber them,
which means we probably
would have been safe
if we waited it out anyway.
And that means we had time to search for
weapons before leaving out of the back.
I would have place useless Hye-Sun
on lookout in a hidden corner
as to not be visible
and even more useless,
and would have gone myself
to search for the armory
if I couldn't find it
within a short period of time,
or if it was empty,
then I would have at least grabbed myself
a stapler or a sharp pen on the way out.
Something at least
the ambulance was a great move,
as you don't want to be caught dead
on foot anyways.
And it has the stuff we need for great
first aid if you need it.
However, forcing it to
crash was not needed.
I would have calmly stated that we wanted
to leave the ambulance
and not to be driven to the hospital.
Or I would have grabbed a sharp scalpel
or some sharpened equipment,
such as a sterile needle,
and would have threatened
the ambulance driver to pull over,
The crash itself, we couldn't have done
much if we were the ones to set it off.
However, assuming
we survived it, which we did,
then I would have first
and foremost picked up a first aid kit
from within the truck
or would have made my own homemade
first aid bag, making sure to collect
various items very likely to be found
within an ambulance like aloe vera gel,
scissors, medical tape, antiinflammatory
drugs, basically enough items to ensure
that we can treat most simple wounds.
Fake ostling, make a splint, treat a burn,
among other things, as bites won't be
the only thing we need to look out for now
that no one's coming to save us.
And it's only a matter of time
until our luck runs out.
After the crash, Hye-Sun and Tank Top Dude
walk out without a scratch
and then make their way towards the metro.
And with a little muscle
and some freak motivation,
they managed to bust their way
through the closed metro entrance.
They don't realize it yet,
but if they don't find somewhere
to hold up, it's only a matter of time
until millions of zombies
come for their throats.
They keep walking with no phone signal
or idea of where they're going, as all
the stations are filled with zombies
Until they Hoehyeon station Hye-Sun
finally gets reception
and calls her boyfriend
to tell him her location just as they run
into another group of terrifying zombies.
They run for their lives
with more and more zombies,
joining the chase, not knowing where
or how they'll make it out of this one
until luck plays to their favor.
They spot a group of men
standing around a makeshift barricaded wall
carrying weapons and balls of steel.
They signal over to Hye-Sun and tank
top you to come over to them quickly.
It's safe to assume
by how they walked out of that metro
that there were no zombies in there.
And so I would have stayed
hidden on the steps just below the streets
line of sight before making that call.
This could have helped them avoid
those first two zombies to begin with
while we waited nice and comfortably
for our rescue to come to us
if we had to expose ourselves
for the sake of catching a phone signal.
She could have at least stayed low
and hidden behind a trashcan or something
and not stand in the middle of
the street like an idiot.
Also, I'd start to worry about my feet,
as you, my dear, still have no shoes on.
Even before an apocalypse.
I could have told you
that walking barefoot in the city
could result in all sorts of nasty things,
sneaking into your foot
to like ring worms.
This was our chance
to at least find some shoes,
potentially better protective
clothing and weaponry lying around.
Because as much as I.
I hate her and love tank top dude,
they're really stupid to not have bothered
to look for any weapons
or better clothing by now.
This would have been one of my top
priorities from the get go,
especially when we have extra moments
of peace and quiet.
Also, we've gone a long while
without any food and water.
The infection has taken over the town
and there are bound to be cars
parked around if we look for a family car.
We may be able to salvage
some food and water and stay hidden inside
and wait for our ex-boyfriend.
If we're lucky enough to find the keys,
we could drive it.
Circling around the block
until our ex-boyfriend reaches us.
And at least this way,
we won't get mouth tagged by zombies.
Hell, we could have driven away
WITHOUT a boyfriend at this point.
Girl power. Now, as much as I'd like
to break into shops to scavenge,
unless we could pick the lock. Breaking in
would have been too noisy.
It is nighttime, after all.
And with the power grid still up,
we definitely would have risked
setting off any potential store alarms
and then we'd definitely be in trouble.
Aside from rating any cars,
I would have also taken this opportunity
to look for any alleys full of dumpsters
where we could have looked for cardboard
and layered materials to wrap up our arms
and legs and to protect us from bites.
And if we salvaged
any tape from the ambulance,
which I talked about earlier,
then we would have at the very least
would have been able
to create some makeshift
zombie armor.
Hye-Sun and Tank Top dude to make it over
to the makeshift barricade.
As Mr. Tough Guy here and his friends
fight off the rest of the zombies
chasing them inside the barricade.
Lots of people sit and stand terrified
as the entire alley is blocked off
one side from the barricade
and the other side by the police
Who are threatening them to leave
as they claim that the scared folk
are participating in an unlawful assembly.
Everybody is trapped
and everyone knows it.
They're on borrowed time.
Hundreds, then thousands
and then millions of zombies
close and quickly, overwhelming Mr.
Tough Guy and his friends
as they struggle to fight them all off.
People are dying left and right
as tank top dude tries to climb the bus,
but is fatally shot, killing him.
The soldiers aren't playing around
and are ready to kill anyone
who tries to climb over that bus,
forcing everybody inside to exit
from the other way
where millions upon
millions of zombies are coming from.
This barricade is about to collapse
as countless zombies close in.
They break through
the barricade to fence as Mr.
Tough Guy and his friends fail to handle
them, resulting in an all you can eat
Korean BBQ as the zombies pounce, chew
and bite their way through everybody.
The smell of walking corpses
and people dying
horrible, bloody deaths is enough
to scare the shit out of Mister Tough Guy
as he gives up and takes off
making a makeshift ladder and begins
climbing over the electric line.
Hye-Sun tries to do the same,
but struggles to hang on just as Mr.
as Tough Guy comes back to give her a hand
and of course, kills
himself in the process.
She manages to climb to safety
for a brief second
before she gets chased
down by more zombies
through an office up the stairs
and onto the roof,
doing crazy stunts
until one of them trips her along
a metal scaffolding
causing her to fall HARD.
You know what I have to commend Hye-Sun
for not getting herself killed sooner.
It's honestly quite impressive
and unbelievable.
Well done. She could have
saved herself and Mr.
Tough Guy if she'd chosen to climb
in a more efficient manner
using the monkey
hung technique,
which is a climbing technique similar
to how monkeys climb,
as this would have been a lot faster
and more efficient,
sparing the weight of the entire body
by using the rope
to support the legs as well.
This would have prevented her
feet from hanging,
swinging like Tarzan on the monkey bars
with their feet hanging was just a recipe
for disaster and explained why only Mr.
Tough Guy had the proper strength to climb
this way. It's way harder.
She made the right move on,
not waiting around,
because even though she was
at a safe vantage
point from before waiting,
there would have only increased the risk
of potentially getting shot or injured
from the already trigger
happy police force.
As they clearly have no idea what's really
going on or who the enemy really is.
After landing on the ledge from the climb,
I would have looked around the building
first, looking through
each of the accessable windows
before making my move.
And I would have taken off my clothing
to wrap around my arm and elbow before
smashing in the window.
Now, we may have taken off
our only bit of clothing,
but this layer around our arms
could have also served as a layer of hand
protection and would have allowed us
to grab a chart of the broken window
glass safely before combating the zombie
that was in the office, giving us an edge
over the zombie with our very own
makeshift weapon.
Hye-Sun was already in a sealed room.
And last time I checked, zombies
can't open doors, at least not easily.
This means in theory,
I could have cleared the hallway room
by room using the opening
and closing of doors as methods
of allowing me to safely control
the entries and exits of this area
without getting bitten by surprise.
Approaching this situation more slowly
and carefully could have
also let us sneak up
on that group of zombies
that Hye-Sun passed.
And if we wanted to,
we could have also close that door,
trapping the zombies in the room.
Hye-Sun's noisy and panicked approach
to this situation
caused a herd of zombies to chase her.
And if we failed to close the door
to the zombies earlier,
we still have another method
of taking them out.
After jumping down from the roof,
Hye-Sun could have stayed put for a sec
before crossing the scaffolding
by letting the stupid zombies
throw themselves from the roofs
like dodos off a cliff.
Also, why is she crossing
on the edge of the metal frame?
It would have been safer to cross
from within the middle.
In case you fell, you'd at least
have a shot to grab onto something.
Hye-Sun wakes up after the fall
and realizes she's on the balcony
of another department.
But is it safe? Injured, tired and afraid?
Hye-Sun calls out for help, but unluckily,
no one in the apartment answers.
Turns out Hye-Sun is in a model apartment
building filled with showroom furniture.
She checks the place out and realizes it's
all model apartments around her
with nobody dead or alive to be seen.
Sad and all alone.
She gives up as she gets a call from her
ex-boyfriend, asking where she is.
She tells him her location
and then sits and waits,
exhausted from all the death around her.
Hye-Sun takes a nap as she comes
to the realization
that everyone she has ever loved
or will love is dead.
And it's only a matter of time
until it's her turn.
Hye-Sun wakes up to her ex-boyfriend
and everything is all happy.
Boyfriend, girlfriend, makeup session
until another older man enters
the apartment. Hye-Sun looks shocked
and terrified as the boyfriend says
he met Hye-Sun's dad at her apartment
earlier that night.
Hye-Sun reveals that this man
is not her dad, but actually her "daddy",
as in her ex pimp.
Turns out Hye-Sun owes Mr Pimp some money.
Pissed off at Hye-Sun,
Mr. Pimp tries to take her
from the ex-boyfriend
as they both get into a fight.
But this fight turns violent,
involving a lot of quick moves.
as Mr. Pimp slices the ex boyfriend's throat.
The ex-boyfriend slowly dies
as Hye-Sun bolts out of there,
turning out to be just as cold
as the corpses. She's running from.
Mr. Pimp goes, searching for Hye-Sun.
Looking in all the model apartments
until Hye-Sun comes from behind and tries
to knock him out with a marble statue.
But Mr. Pimp is too damn
quick for poor old ice queen.
Hye-Sun as he blocks her and beats her to
the ground crossing Hye-Sun to pass out.
Holy crap, this girl can't catch a break.
First thing I would have done is checked
for injuries and bruises because
apparently we're Korean superwoman.
Next, I would have checked security
for the building,
even venturing down those stairs
to see if everything
was properly locked down
and that there were no zombies
down there for defense.
We could have brought along the knife
from the fake kitchen.
And by falling into this apartment model,
we've already secured
a possible rest location.
It being nightime means that this place
would have already been closed
and locked down for hours
and has more than enough
beds for me and my ego.
I also would have looked
for a vending machine or a fridge
containing water
as this being a model apartment.
It's not crazy to think
that they would have had stocks of water
for guests already available nearby.
These are the first few things
I would have done before
calling our ex-BAE in regards
to our ex-boyfriend and our pimp daddy.
Hye-Sun acted useless till the end.
There were several items in that apartment
that Hye-Sun could have used
to try and take Mr.
Pimp out before and after
he already had that knife from the chair
to the pot to the glasses and plates.
Pretty much anything in that kitchen
could have been used.
But while driving the chair into Mr.
Pimp would have made for a good tactical
barrier between his knife and our flesh.
Hye-Sun could have grabbed
the knife when Mr.
Pimp was busy killing our ex-boyfriend.
There were bunches of knives
available to her, and she could have
easily sliced his neck or cut
right through his accessable armpit,
hitting the shallow
axillary artery located right
beneath the surface of the armpit,
and one RV that could have done
some serious damage if cut.
However, running away from Mr.
Pimp was also a solid move,
although she simply could have hid behind
an entranceway door
on the side away from the door hinge,
allowing her to have full access to Mr.
Pimp as he would have entered,
grabbing his knife with one hand
and stabbing him with the other, seriously
injuring him before running away again.
This would have been a much safer option
and would have saved us
from directly taking him on.
An unconscious Hye-Sun was taken by Mr. Pimp
as he readies to “take her” on the bed.
However, he slowly notices
that Hye-Sun isn't breathing.
Mr. Pimp is scared and afraid, trying
to bring Hye-Sun back to life
as he begs for her forgiveness.
Although in the middle of all of this,
he notices a scratch on Hye-Sun's right ankle,
and a scary infection
taking over her body.
HOOOOOOLY crap
as he looks right up, he sees his very own
zombie nightmare right up close,
like a scared child
in front of a deadly snake.
Mr Pimp tries to back away
just as Hye-Sun pounces on him, eagerly
devouring her new man meal.
We look up to see a destroyed city
with a zombie infection now slowly
but surely taking over the entire nation
as we look onto a destroyed Seoul,
just as the sun rises
for the next day, right on time
for the final departing train to Busan.